.
NOT, WHEN.
♪ ♪
THE POLITICAL COVERAGE.
THAT LOOK, UM, SOME OF THE
POLITICAL PLAYERS IN SOME OF
THE...
LET ME ASK AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
NO, I WANT TO.
ANYWAY.
>> Sean: RON, DO YOU OR ANYONE
ELSE AT THE WHITE HOUSE FEEL BAD
PUTTING JOE IN THAT POSITION
EVERY DAY?
YOU ARE LIVING IN AN ALTERNATE
REALITY.
THE ENTIRE PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN A
HORROR SHOW BOTH AT HOME AND
ABROAD.
AND BY THE WAY, JOE'S WALL
DEFINITELY DOES NOT GO TO THE
OFFICE OR THE OVAL OFFICE EVERY
MORNING AS YOU CLAIM.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
SO FAR JOE BIDEN HAS SPENT 150
WHOPPING DAYS ON VACATION IN
DELAWARE.
IN THIS WEEKEND IS HEADED BACK
TO THE BEACH IN DELAWARE AFTER A
LENGTHY VACATION IN CAROLINA
WHERE HE IS GOING TO BUILD A
WALL TO SECURE HIS PROMISES.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT SERIOUS ABOUT
HIS WORK BECAUSE HE IS NOT
MENTALLY CAPABLE OF BEING
SERIOUS ABOUT WORK.
HE CAN A MAN PUT HIS OWN JACKET
ON.
LIKE A FUNCTIONING ADULTS.
BUT IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, IT
JUST SIMPLY DOES NOT MATTER.
DEMOCRATS DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S MENTAL
DECLINE, HIS COGNITIVE DECLINE
OR THE DISASTER IN AFGHANISTAN.
NOW A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
INFLATION, HIGH GAS PRICES, AND
DON'T EVEN CARE THAT JOE'S SON
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER APPEARS
TO HAVE SOLD ACCESS TO THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE U.S.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALL TO MAKE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF CHINA RUSSIA,
UKRAINE, AND MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT DON'T
PARTICULARLY LIKE THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO REVERE
OUR INSTITUTIONS.
NO, THEY DON'T REVERE OUR
INSTITUTIONS, THEY ONLY CARE
ABOUT POLITICAL POWER, RAW
POLITICAL POWER, BUT DON'T TAKE
MY WORD FOR IT, JUST LISTEN TO A
POPULAR LIBERAL PODCAST HOST.
HIS NAME IS SAM HARRIS, HE JUST
SAYS WHAT OTHERS THINK.
>> TRUMP UNIVERSITY IS A STORY
IS WORSE THAN ANYTHING THAT
COULD BE IN HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP IN MY VIEW.
NOW THAT IS NOT --
THAT DOES NOT ANSWER THE PEOPLE
THAT SAY IT'S STILL COMPLETELY
UNFAIR TO NOT HAVE LOOKED AT THE
LAPTOP IN A TIMELY WAY AND TO
HAVE SHUT DOWN
"THE NEW YORK POST" TWITTER
ACCOUNT.
LIKE THAT IS JUST --
THAT IS A LEFT-WING CONSPIRACY
TO DENY THE PRESIDENCY TO
DONALD TRUMP.
ABSOLUTELY IT WAS.
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT I THINK THAT IT WAS
WARRANTED.
>> Sean: IT'S A MEANS TO AN
END, NO INTELLECTUAL HONESTY TO
THE TRUTH OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF TODAY, THEY
WILL LIE, THEY WILL CHEAT, THEY
WILL STEAL THEIR WAY TO THE TOP
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO GAIN
POWER AND THEY WILL DO IT
TOGETHER WITH ONE UNITED VOICE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SO-CALLED
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT OR I
CALL IT THAT THE TAX OF THE POOR
COME IN THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOME ACT, ALL
IT IS IS ONE GIANT $500 BILLION
FORCE AND IT DOES NOT EVEN
ATTEMPT TO REDUCE INFLATION.
IT WILL INCREASE INFLATION.
IT INCREASES TAXES ON THE POOR,
MIDDLE-CLASS, FIXED INCOMES AND
DRIVES UP EVERYBODY'S ENERGY
COST AT A TIME WHEN GAS IS STILL
NEAR A RECORD HIGH AND HAS 85 TO
857 NEW AGENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES, BIGGER THAN THREE
AGENCIES OF THE GOVERNMENT
COMBINED.
BUT GUESS WHAT, OF THE AMERICANS
THEY WILL NOW BE ABLE TO ENJOY A
BIG TAX CREDIT.
IF THEY CAN BUY AN EXPENSIVE NEW
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR AN EV AS
THEY LIKE TO CALL THEM, EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE
VOTED IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THEY DON'T CARE IF AMERICANS GET
HURT, THEY JUST WANT A POLITICAL
WIN.
THEIR GREEN CLIMATES RELIGIOUS
CULT TRUMPS EVERYTHING.
TO THESE SAME DEMOCRATS ARE
REPAINTING REPUBLICAN SENATE
CANDIDATES IN UPCOMING ELECTIONS
AND MIDTERMS AS CRUEL AND OUT OF
TOUCH.
WELL APPARENTLY SENATE MINORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL IS
CONTENT TO LEAVE THEM OUT TO DRY
AND FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
THESE COMMENTS ARE VERY
ENCOURAGING.
>> PROBABLY A GREATER LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE HOUSE SPLITS IN THE
SENATE.
THE SENATE RACES ARE JUST
DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE STABILIZED STATEWIDE
CANDIDATE QUALITY HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH THE OUTCOME.
>> Tucker: CANDIDATE QUALITY
COMING IN LIKE IN PENNSYLVANIA
THAT DEMOCRATIC SENATE
CANDIDATES, A DEVOUT SOCIALIST
STYLE IN THE VEIN OF LESSEE,
BERNIE SANDERS BERNIE SANDERS
WHO HE ENDORSED OVER JOE BIDEN.
A GUY THAT LITERALLY CAN'T PUT
TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER HIMSELF.
HAS ONLY BEEN 11 MINUTES ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, THE GUY THAT
WANTS TO LEGALIZE HEROIN AND
HAVE AREAS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
SHOOT UP IN PUBLIC AND I HOPE
THAT HE GETS BETTER HEALTHWISE,
BUT IT'S JUST A SIMPLE FACT.
HE IS TO THE LEFT OR
BERNIE SANDERS AND YET YOU DON'T
HEAR CHUCK SCHUMER COMPLAINING
ABOUT CANDIDATE QUALITY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HOW ABOUT YOU GET OUT THERE,
MITCH, AND FIGHT FOR YOUR TEAM.
WHAT'S YOUR AGENDA, MITCH, OR
WOULD YOU RATHER JUST SIT BY AND
WATCH HELPLESSLY AS DEMOCRATS
LIE TO YOUR FACE, PASS ANOTHER
$500 BILLION GREEN ENERGY
BOONDOGGLE.
NEXT YEAR, OR IS IT MAY BE
MITCH McCONNELL ONCE
DONALD TRUMP SO MUCH THAT HE
WOULD PROBABLY RATHER SEE
TRUMPED ENDORSED CANDIDATES
LOSE, THIS TIME AS A LEADER
NEEDS TO COME TO AN END.
IF REPUBLICANS FAILED TO TAKE
THE MAJORITY WE WILL GET EVEN
MORE TAXIS AND AUDITS AND MORE
INFLATION, WE WILL GET MORE
SOCIALISM, WE WILL GET MORE
GREEN NEW DEAL, MORE MASS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, THAT MEANS
MORE FRIENDS AND ALL, MORE
HEROIN, MORE CRIME, MORE CHAOS,
MORE CARNAGE AND A FAR LEFT
DEEP STATE BUREAUCRACY LEFT
TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
UNCHECKED, THIS IS A CRITICAL
INFLECTION POINT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
OF CRITICAL MOMENT, A TIPPING
POINT.
IF MITCH DOES NOT WANT TO HELP
LEAD TO HIS PARTY, STEP ASIDE,
WI